just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years what
is one thing that they would carry with
them the Quran why because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets brothers and sisters imagine you
have a app the Quran app which not only
shows you how much rewards you get but
reminds you to read the Quran gives you
reminders download the Quran app now and
let it testify for you on your that you
read it wherever you was
good to see all the
brothers I just came back
from to work is in Mexico I I was in
Mexico last weekend now right now I'm in
Canada alhamdulillah this is the life of
you know you're always on the move so uh
in Mexico you know we we saw really a
place that really needed it you know I
mean we have a lot of brothers that have
accepted Islam a lot of them in remote
areas um you know alhamdulillah there
are some good Brothers down there that
are putting work in that are giving da
in the streets but at the same time you
know a lot of the brothers like when we
went the day we went they had six Shas
alhamdulillah a lot of them they didn't
know how to read fat they didn't know
how to pray and we have maybe a couple
of brothers that are knowledgeable that
were teaching you know at least 20
people that are there you know and then
W even even amongst those Brothers a lot
of them live in remote areas so when we
went out there alhamdulillah we had Anar
at the mjid there a lot of the people
came from far away areas because they
knew we were coming out but you'll see a
lot of kids alhamdulillah they became
Muslim they're the only Muslims in their
family you know and then when they go
back to their remote areas there's no
mjid around them there's no Muslims
around them so alhamdulillah you know
this is why when you when I talked to
you earlier about this project I thought
about Mexico and I thought about the
need and other areas even in America
right now we have a lot of people in
very remote areas that are accepting
Islam that don't even have a mjid in
their City people right now we know that
are undercover Muslims you know we have
we have a brother right now in San Diego
he's Mexican uh 17-year-old brother you
know got caught up in the wrong stuff
gang stuff uh you know got caught up in
some court cases and you know six
attempts on his life and Subhan Allah
started watching uh a lot of our videos
especially a video about my life how it
used to be and how it changed and he
decided to change and he talked to one
of the brothers alhamdulillah and he
took a shahada came to the Masjid but
now he has to come to the Masjid like
secretly you know because he can't even
his family who had to move because of
you know the dangers that they were
having with him getting shot at but
still they're not okay with him becoming
Muslim so you know we brought up for the
other day he had to come secretly you
know he had to tell his family I'm going
to the store and he came so people like
that if we can get these kinds of prayer
mats to him it would be a great resource
for him you know there was a revert
sister who took her shahada uh with with
us about three years ago so what
happened is I can remember when we first
launched the Salah plus program we were
doing a Salah Workshop so we got sister
Lauren Bo came she was doing like a
workshop for the sisters and the
brothers we were just talking about
Salah anyway she on the day we were
doing the Salah Workshop we nearly
finished it towards the end it was like
it was around 9:30 10 p.m. we was going
to start wrapping up W Allah is my
witness I had a I had a phone call so I
didn't know who it was from I didn't
know what I sa the number so I picked up
and he was like yeahum do you remember
me I was like no I can't remember he
remember from South End I was like I
can't remember remember that sister I
came with and I said I was looking for a
number for two weeks he calls me on the
day of the Salah Workshop I said a I've
been looking for you for two weeks your
number I didn't know what I saved you
under yeah so anyways he goes listen
she's in a bad place I said what
happened he that she's crying Etc I said
what happened he said look can we come
and speak I said listen we can wait for
you so it's an hour and a half Journey
we waited for them for one and a half
hour she came and my wife was there
sister Lauren R was there she went and
spoke to them you know what she said to
them she said since I've come to Islam I
stopped eating pork I stopped drinking
alcohol I don't go clubbing wow and we
said what's the problem she said I feel
empty she goes I don't know I just feel
empty simple question we asked her we
said are you praying Salah she said no
and we said Subhan Allah this is exactly
the issue the Salah is the Soul's food
the Vick of Allah is the Soul's food if
you starve it of course the body is
saying I need something it's the Vick of
Allah that's why Allah says in the Quran
only in his remembrance do hearts find
peace and if you forget his remebrance
you have a depressed life so even though
she was a Muslim she was thinking not
eating pork not drinking alcohol not
going clubbing it will feed the soul it
wouldn't that might protect your body
but the point is what Salah that's the
reason why many after care issues when
people accept Islam how many of us have
the time to teach them to pra Salah I
mean if it's one person you wouldn't
have no problem teaching one person or
five people but imagine 100 people come
to you and say there's 100 of us please
teach us you're going to say I don't I
can't do this so this is the reason why
we have this program in place especially
people that are far away I mean you know
so inshallah uh before anybody else I'm
ready to donate $1,000 on my own money
inah to this program no
way subh want to ask anybody else to do
what I'm not willing to do so inshallah
a thousand
us we accept the currency of US Dollars
and we know Allah will accept inshallah
that deed inshah with so $1,000 sister
will help teach 166 to 332 people how to
pray Salah let me tell you why let me
I'm just going to go to a quick video
she if you just give us two minutes this
is a story of an ex-muslim and a new
Muslim now this ex-muslim he left Islam
and then he came back to Islam then he
signed up to our program he relearned
Surah fa he relearned W he relearned
Salah then do you know what he did she
we gave him a guided prayer mat do you
know what he did with it he learned how
to pray in six weeks he gifted this to
his revert
friend his friend is now learning how to
playay with this with his that he gifted
to him May bless you we're gonna let you
go because we know you need to go to the
Masid really appreciate it may bless TR
later owe me some you owe me some kurish
Kebab man come on send me
location